[Music]
it was a day for pipes and drums for
family for Farnum a day for an
inauguration
seven months after Farnum Jahan Ian was
officially named president by the Board
of Trustees
he walked into Wiegand gym it was
installed as the tenth leader in the
history of Carnegie Mellon University I
hereby accept the symbols the Office of
the President and all of the
responsibilities pertaining thereto
dr. Farnum jahannum is the right leader
at the right time to guide our great
university forward a prominent scientist
creative entrepreneur public servant and
esteemed educator Farnum Jahan Ian
brings the experience passion and
leadership necessary to steer CMU search
committees look for university
presidents who fit their University and
I can't imagine Carnegie Mellon finding
someone who fits better than Farnum he
will be a brilliant and inspired leader
for this wonderful University and who
knows he may even learn to play the
bagpipes I am committed to supporting
this leadership by investing in a
diverse community of faculty and
researchers by doubling down on our
partnership beyond the borders of our
campus and by creating vibrant living
laboratories in communities around the
world this is the next frontier for
Carnegie Mellon and I believe it will
only deepen our societal impact heading
into the future Jehan Ian used the
speech to make two major announcements
first the Allegheny foundation pledged a
30 million dollar lead grant that will
demolish and totally rebuild Scafe Hall
it'll be the new home of the department
of mechanical engineering and Todd and
Cindy Johnson who graduated from
Carnegie Mellon back in the 1960s
pledged 50 million dollars to start an
endowment for undergraduate scholarships
it's the largest gift in Carnegie Mellon
history toward scholarships and on a day
of many emotions it proved to be the
most emotional of them all I made the
announcement a couple of times yesterday
and I said this last night every time
I'm making this announcement when I get
to the word student I choke up that's
why we're here I feel privileged to work
with such outstanding partners and I
look forward to all that we will achieve
together thank you very much
[Applause]